um hey so I found this out about you
which is crazy
your dad is I-20 from dtp yeah
disturbing the piece you wanna know your
dad has one of the most distinct illest
voices in rap history yeah pops crazy
show his voice is so crazy his voice is
dead deep in real life too bro it's like
damn yeah I loved I-20 bro yeah I love
him too that's my dad I mean I hope so
right
were you like around like Ludacris and
[ __ ] growing up 100 I was like he your
uncle yeah definitely Chris
like it was like times when my pops get
mad cause like as a child like I
wouldn't understand it I'd be calling
little kids I'm like look at this
Ludacris like bro it's like my best
friend right
she's crazy did you like would you
attribute just being around your dad
to your rap career like you wanting to
pursue that
at first I used to say I didn't but like
growing up and like thinking like how
much that [ __ ] like really like was in
my brain hell yeah like it's pictures of
me on the internet like when I was a kid
like recording I'm like but I'm like in
my dad's studio right so it's like [ __ ]
like that but when I was growing up I
definitely was like [ __ ] rap I'm not on
this and then like over time I kind of
got into it and then now growing up in
it and like having this [ __ ] happened to
me I kind of like understand everything
a lot more with that yeah there was a
guy from I'm from Phoenix Arizona right
yeah and uh we had one guy kind of
really make it nationally for a sec and
it was uh Willie North Pole who was
signed to dtp that's crazy would you
ever hear Willie North Pole I ain't
gonna lie I've never heard of Willie
came and went but I mean he's still
having shout out to William it's my guy
good guy but like he put out one album
on dtp and then it kind of went away but
you know shout out to us yeah
your pops ever give you like [ __ ]
tips on some bars because he's a [ __ ]
real lyrical [ __ ] no first
rapping each side like tried to kick it
to me like I was on him [ __ ] [ __ ] right
like now it's like he definitely respect
the way I rap He was just at um our last
show on our tour in Atlanta my parents
pulled up he definitely spread this [ __ ]
that's super dope what about uh what
about Uncle Luda ain't gonna lie I spoke
to him in a minute but my pops talk to
him all the time like yo yo what Sun's
going crazy right now I don't think you
understand 100 they definitely everybody
from over there love everything I'm
doing and they respect it I feel like
I'm doing good for them I ain't just
being [ __ ] crazy or stupid